mistakes are always forgivable
if one has the courage to admit them
be happy but never satisfied
[Music]
absorb what is useful discard what is
not
add what is uniquely your own
[Music]
showing off is the fool's idea of glory
long-term consistency trumps short-term
intensity
preparation for tomorrow is hard work
today
a wise man can learn more from a foolish
question
than a fool can learn from a wise answer
a goal is not always meant to be reached
it often serves simply as something to
aim at
the possession of anything begins in the
mind
if you don't want to slip up tomorrow
speak the truth today
a good teacher protects his pupils from
his own influence
knowledge will earn you power
but character will earn you respect
[Music]
obey the principles without being bound
by them
it's not what you give it's the way you
give it
[Music]
a quick temper will make a fool of you
soon enough
empty your cup so that it may be filled
become devoid to gain everything
[Music]
the less effort the faster and more
powerful you will be
the key to immortality is first living a
life worth remembering
[Music]
take things as they are
punch when you have to punch kick when
you have to kick
[Music]
use only that which works
and take it from any place you can find
it
boards don't hit back
knowing is not enough we must apply our
knowledge
willing is not enough we must do
[Music]
what you think determines what you will
become
life is wide limitless there is no
border no frontier
the spirit of the individual is
determined by his dominating thought
habits
don't get stuck into one form
build your own form adapt it let it grow
be like water
be self-aware rather than a repetitious
robot
using no way is a way
having no limitation has a limitation
i am not teaching you anything
i just help you explore yourself
[Music]
those who are unaware they are walking
in darkness will never seek the light
[Music]
all knowledge is self-knowledge
[Music]
a fight is not won by one punch or kick
either learn to endure or hire a
bodyguard
[Music]
defeat is a state of mind
no one is ever defeated until defeat has
been accepted as a reality
learning is never cumulative it is a
movement of knowing which has no
beginning and no end
endurance is rapidly lost if one ceases
to work at its maximum
do not allow negative thoughts to enter
your mind they are the weeds that
strangle confidence
remember no man is really defeated
unless he is discouraged
[Music]
only the self-sufficient stand alone
most people follow the crowd and imitate
[Music]
i'm not in this world to live up to your
expectations and you're not in this
world to live up to mine
man the living creature the creating
individual
is always more important than any
established style or system
if you want to learn to swim jump in the
water
on dry land no frame of mind is ever
going to help you
notice that the stiffest tree is most
easily cracked
while the bamboo or willow survives by
bending with the wind
all fixed patterns are incapable of
adaptability or pliability
the truth is outside of all fixed
patterns
the knowledge and skills you have
achieved are meant to be forgotten so
you can float comfortably in emptiness
without obstruction
the stillness and stillness is not the
real stillness
only when there is stillness in movement
does the universal rhythm manifest
[Music]
time means a lot to me because i am also
a learner and i'm often lost in the joy
of forever developing
do not deny the classical approach
simply as a reaction
or you will have created another pattern
and trapped yourself there
like a finger pointing to the moon
don't concentrate on the finger
or you will miss all that heavenly glory
[Music]
what is is more important than what
should be too many people are looking at
what is
from a position of thinking what should
be
i fear not the man who has practiced ten
thousand kicks once
i fear the man who has practiced one
kick ten thousand times
[Music]
if you spend too much time thinking
about a thing you'll never get it done
make at least one definite move daily
toward your goal
always be yourself express yourself have
faith in yourself
do not look for a successful personality
to duplicate
empty your mind be formless shapeless
like water
if you put water into a cup it becomes
the
cup if there is a god he is within
you don't ask god to give you things you
depend on god for your inner theme
[Music]
choose the positive you have choice you
are the master of your attitude
choose the positive the constructive
optimism is a faith that leads to
success
life is never stagnation it is constant
movement
unrhythmic movement
as we constantly change
things live by moving and gain strength
as they go
the doubters say man cannot fly the
doers say
maybe let's try
and finally soared in the morning glow
while the non-believers watched from
below
reality is apparent one one ceases to
compare
there is what is only when there is no
comparison at all
to live with what is is to be peaceful
life's battles don't always go to the
stronger or faster man
but sooner or later the man who wins is
the man who thinks he can
in order to control myself i must first
accept myself by going with and not
against my nature
[Music]
you